Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux ! Aujourd'hui, je vous parle d'un appareil
qu'on utilise tous, je vous le dis en anglais "the microwaves". "Waves", vagues.
En français,
le micro-ondes est idéal pour transformer les grains de maïs en popcorn.
Mais est-ce que c'est bon pour la santé ?
Peut-on tout mettre dedans ?
Je suis chaud pour vous expliquer tout ça.
Comme beaucoup d'objets du quotidien,
le micro-ondes
que l'on trouve dans nos cuisines
a été inventé par hasard.
C'est aussi le cas des Post-it ou du Velcro.
Mais ça, je vous l'expliquerai dans une autre vidéo.
Revenons au micro-ondes.
À la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
Percy Spencer, un ingénieur américain,
travaille sur le nouveau modèle
d'un appareil appelé le magnétron.
Rien à voir avec la cuisine.
A l'époque, le magnétron est
un élément utilisé dans les radars
pour mieux repérer les avions en plein vol grâce à des ondes ultra-courtes.
Selon la légende, un jour,
alors qu'il a un petit creux et qu'il
retire de sa poche une barre chocolatée,
le scientifique constate qu'elle a fondue.
Il a alors une idée : placer des grains de maïs
devant le magnétron. Et là, stupéfaction !
Il fait des popcorns. Oups !
C'est ainsi que le four à micro-ondes est né.
Le premier modèle mis en vente
est baptisé Radarange et franchement,
il n'est pas hyper pratique.
Il faut avoir une grande cuisine
puisqu'il mesure 1,80m et pèse plus de 300 kg.
Vous imaginez ! Aussi volumineux
qu'un gros réfrigérateur et le poids d'un cheval.
Pour se le procurer, il fallait alors débourser entre 2 000 $ et 3000 $.
C'est l'équivalent aujourd'hui de 30000 $.
Alors forcément, au début,
le micro-ondes est micro utilisé.
Seulement dans les cantines militaires
et les hôpitaux.
C'est au milieu des années 1950
que l'appareil commence à faire son entrée
dans les foyers américains.
En Europe, il faudra attendre les années 1970
pour que les premiers micro-ondes
soient adoptés par les ménages.
Et encore, pas tous. A l'époque,
c'est un produit de luxe.
Il coûtait jusqu'à 6 000 francs.
Autrement dit, dix fois le salaire mensuel minimum.
Puis, avec l'engouement des plats préparés dans les années 1980
et 1990 et les progrès de la technologie,
son prix baisse
et le micro-ondes devient peu à peu
un incontournable des cuisines.
Aujourd'hui, selon l'Insee, 90% des foyers français en possèdent un.
Et s'il s'est modernisé, le principe reste le même.
C'est celui du magnétron.
Magnétron ?
C'est un personnage de science-fiction ça.
Mais non, ce n'est pas de la fiction,
c'est de la science tout court.
Les micro-ondes,
et je ne parle pas de l'objet,
sont des ondes électromagnétiques.
Elles sont de la même nature que la lumière émise par une ampoule.
Mais comme les infrarouges ou
les ultraviolets, elles sont invisibles.
Elles font également partie
de la même famille que les ondes utilisées
par la radio, les vieilles télévisions
et même le Wi-Fi. Comme toutes les ondes,
elles sont caractérisées
par leur fréquence, c'est-à-dire
le nombre d'oscillations en une seconde.
Cette fréquence se mesure en Hertz.
Les micro-ondes oscillent à une fréquence
de 2450 MHz.
J'ai bien dit Méga.
Autrement dit, elles oscillent
2 450 millions de fois par seconde.
Ah oui, ça bouge sacrément quand même.
Oui, ça bouge beaucoup.
Et en contrepartie, les ondes sont extrêmement courtes.
Fréquence élevée, ondes très courtes.
C'est ça le secret. Allez, en cuisine !
Quand on met un plat au micro-ondes,
les aliments sont bombardés d'ondes électromagnétiques
qui les traversent, et en les traversant,
les molécules d'eau
contenues dans les aliments
se mettent à bouger.
Elles se cognent les unes aux autres.
Bref, elles se mettent elles aussi à osciller et sacrément vite,
au même rythme que les ondes.
C'est ce mouvement, cette agitation,
qui produit de l'énergie et de la chaleur.
Le même phénomène se produit lorsqu'on se frotte les mains.
Ça chauffe.
Mais revenons au popcorn.
Les grains de maïs contiennent de l'eau,
des lipides et de l'amidon.
Sous l'effet des micro-ondes,
les molécules d'eau s'agitent,
la température monte, l'eau se transforme en vapeur.
Elle occupe un plus grand volume que l'eau liquide.
La pression monte.
L'amidon est repoussé à la périphérie
et devient visqueux jusqu'au moment
où la pression est trop forte.
L'enveloppe éclate.
L'amidon est projeté à l'extérieur
et tout cela va très vite
en moins de deux minutes seulement.
Au passage, c'est pour la même raison
que certains récipients explosent
quand vous le mettez au micro-ondes.
En général, ils contiennent des plats dont les aliments contiennent beaucoup d'eau
et dont le récipient est fermé
hermétiquement.
Ça nous est tous arrivé.
L'eau se transforme en vapeur, fait
pression et le couvercle finit par sauter.
D'où la nécessité d'entrouvrir le couvercle ou de le percer
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un film plastique,
ce qui permet à la vapeur de s'échapper.
Moi, ce qui m'inquiète, c'est le rayonnement.
Ce n'est pas un peu dangereux pour la santé ?
En cas de contact direct avec la peau,
oui, le rayonnement peut être nocif
et provoquer des brûlures.
Mais pas de panique, lorsqu'il
est en marche et que la porte est fermée,
le rayonnement reste confiné à l'intérieur de l'appareil.
Je vais vous montrer.
Une grille très serrée,
que l'on voit à travers la porte,
tendue dessus, l'empêche de passer.
L'enceinte du four, quant à elle, forme une cage métallique
qui piège les micro-ondes.
On appelle ça une cage de Faraday.
Métallique ?
J'ai entendu dire que micro-ondes
et métal, ça ne faisait pas bon ménage.
En fait, les parois du four
reflètent les micro-ondes qui se propagent dans l'appareil.
Il est conçu pour ça.
Il ne faut jamais y mettre d'objets
métalliques qui ont des bords saillants.
Une boîte de conserve, par exemple,
une cuillère ou une fourchette,
ou même une assiette ou une tasse avec des dorures.
Ces objets ne contiennent pas d'eau.
L'énergie des micro-ondes,
n'est pas absorbé, en revanche,
elle met en mouvement les électrons
contenus dans le métal qui s'accumulent au niveau des angles, au niveau des pointes.
C'est ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs l'effet de pointe.
Quand il y en a trop,
la tension provoque une décharge,
un arc électrique, un petit éclair,
si vous préférez.
Et ça, ça peut être dangereux.
Pour éviter de prendre des risques,
moi, je n'utilise que des contenants
en plastique.
Enfin, il y a plastique et plastique, j'explique.
Sous l'effet de la chaleur,
certains peuvent libérer des substances toxiques.
Ce serait le cas, par exemple,
du bisphénol A, reconnu comme un perturbateur endocrinien.
S'il est désormais interdit à la vente
en France, certaines
boîtes en plastique qui en contiennent
sont toujours en circulation.
Un conseil, donc.
Débarrassez-vous
des vieux récipients en plastique qui traînent dans vos placards.
En fait, un logo figure sur les boîtes en plastique
qui sont compatibles avec les micro-ondes.
Et puis, si vous avez un doute,
le mieux, c'est d'utiliser un plat en verre ou en céramique.
Ça marche même avec le carton.
Moi, j'ai entendu dire que les micro-ondes pouvaient contaminer les aliments.
Alors soyons clairs, non !
Une fois chauffée, votre nourriture
ne devient pas radioactive.
En plus, les micro-ondes permettent
de préserver les nutriments
contenus dans les aliments,
un peu comme la cuisson à la vapeur.
Utilisé correctement, le micro-ondes est
donc un moyen sûr et sain de cuisiner.
Ah, je crois que mon petit plat est prêt.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, vous pouvez mettre
un pouce bleu et vous abonner à la chaîne.
C'est juste en dessous de moi.
Allez, à très, très vite,
chers Epicurieuses et Epicurieux.